I made a comment in July that EDH has effectively
become the casual way to play paper Magic. And
it really has—the days of 60 card kitchen table
gaming are in the past, replaced by a diverging
path for newer players: either play Arena and
get your 1v1 fix from the comfort of your couch,
or meet up with three other people and play
commander. The nostalgic part of me certainly
wants to push back against this, and I’ve spoken
before about some reasons why commander perhaps
isn’t the best on-ramp for newer players. But,
there are some clear upsides to commander—the
fact that it’s a casual format by designation
rather than being casual gameplay on the fringes
of competitive formats means a much greater
degree of stability than something like 60
card kitchen table magic, a format whose current
form basically vanishes off the face of the earth
whenever the friends who want to play it with
you stop wanting to play it. More importantly,
commander as a format clearly isn’t
going anywhere in the casual scene,
so it’s pointless to try and fight against it.
That said, the collapse of 60 card casual Magic,
along with the slow decline in the popularity of
draft that I’ve noticed over the last ten years,
have had me thinking—what are we losing, exactly?
What impact is it having that there is a growing
population of commander players who have played
little-to-none of other formats? To be clear,
this isn’t intended as old man grumbling—I
can certainly get old man grumbly sometimes
as somebody who has been playing Magic for
more than half of my life, and maybe I’d
be more old man grumbly if I were a Modern player
or something. But no, this is a genuine question,
and to get some insight into it, I’m going to
answer a slightly different set of questions
in this video: what does the experience of playing
formats that aren’t commander endow upon a player?
What impact might that sort of experience have
on the way they play commander? And, do these
impacts make it worth venturing outside EDH
from time to time for us primarily EDH players?
To start with, let’s talk about the gameplay
experience of a 20 health 1v1 format. A defining
feature of these formats as compared to commander
is that they’re low slung and grindy, with smaller
threats being much more relevant. With this fact
in mind, what I’m about to say may initially seem
a bit confusing, that being that playing these
formats can directly help with building the
skills required for playing commander. Commander
and 20 health formats certainly are different,
but counterintuitively this is exactly why it
can be helpful to have played the latter—it can
give a player better breadth of experience.
See, playing commander gives players lots of
experience in fighting against big, bombastic
wincons—for starters you’ve got the obvious
examples like combo decks and combo-adjacent
plays like a massive X spell or a Craterhoof
on a board full of tokens, plays that reduce one
or more life totals to zero in one fell swoop and
often do so with large excesses of damage.
However, even outside of these, life total
can frequently feel irrelevant in EDH, regardless
of whether it is or not. Even with a conventional
big creatures midrange deck without a splashy
singular finisher, a lot of times most damage
will be dealt in one or two attack swings. This
comes down to the snowbally nature of a lot of
EDH decks—all sorts of cards are intended to push
a deck to greater and greater volumes of gameplay,
whether that be effect doublers or mana doublers
or other forms of action-compounding engines.
This often means that decks buckle down until
they have a massive board of creatures to
attack with before swinging wide, sometimes
for entire life totals in one go. Somebody
might have to count out 35 damage to this
player, 29 damage to that player, and so on,
and under that context opponents don’t even
really need to think about their life total
regardless of if a handful of points of difference
would have been relevant or not. Like c’mon,
you lost because the opponent popped off, simple
as. However, what this means is that commander
players are often less prepared for grindier
games where every point of life total matters.
The results of this can be seen when it comes to
blocking and life total management—players who
are more experienced in formats where life totals
are relevant will be much more careful of certain
life total thresholds, and more willing to block
to stay above them. Players of 20 health formats
learn to internalize the idea that life total is
a resource, and to know when to spend and when to
save that resource, but commander players
who have spent a lot of time dealing with
bigger one-or-two-shot wincons won’t internalize
this lesson nearly as quickly. EDH’s higher life
totals also train players to mostly disregard
the idea of blocking with useful creatures,
because it feels better to keep them around and
most of the time that’s the correct decision
in strategy terms as well. Unlike in a 20 health
format where blocking with a key creature to stay
alive for an extra turn or two is a very common
necessity that players get used to biting the
bullet on, this isn’t necessary nearly as often in
EDH due to higher life totals and heftier wincons,
and this means that when it becomes a necessity
a lot of players instinctually refuse to do it,
even when it means sacrificing an amount
of life that will almost certainly lose
them a game. Another aspect of non-commander
gameplay, and particularly limited formats,
is low-resource environments where players are
topdecking or working under tight constraints
in some other way. These games aren’t wildly
common in commander due to how common ramp
and draw are—with variation by playgroup,
obviously—and this means that you need to
play a lot more EDH to get comfortable under these
circumstances than you would to get comfortable
under more common EDH scenarios. The results
of this can be quite problematic—when a game
has involved some form of stax or heavy
attrition and resources are dwindling,
you can usually tell who has played other
formats and who hasn’t. A lot of primarily
EDH players will be looking at the situation as
a lost cause, a game gone wildly off the rails,
whereas people who have done their time in the
trenches of limited or 60 card formats will
be more engaged and vigilant, looking for outs
and bits of incremental advantage to grab onto.
Outside of gameplay, the experience of building
60 card decks can help with EDH deckbuilding as
well. One way this can manifest is when building
decks which are exceptions to traditional norms of
EDH deckbuilding. See, people tend to have rough
templates they follow when they build commander
decks, myself included—a low double digits
number of draw spells is good for maintaining
a consistent stream of cards turn over turn, maybe
more if those draw spells are smaller or less if
the deck has other ways to compound value or
tutors to find its value engines. Likewise,
a low double digits amount of ramp will
be good for a deck that wants to have a
single piece of ramp most games but is fine
occasionally not having one, and adjustments
can be made up or down depending on how often a
deck wants ramp, what size of ramp a deck wants,
and how aggressively a player is willing
to mulligan. These are references I follow,
and I like them as a starting point because
they’re flexible—they prescribe numbers of
cards based on what a deck wants to do and what
other tools a deck has available to it. However,
the trouble comes when references like these are
less flexible, and when they’re treated as gospel
regardless of what deck they’re being applied to.
Ramp is a great example for demonstrating this,
because it’s one of the biggest differences
between EDH and other formats. Basically all
EDH decks have some amount of ramp in them, and
most have a decent amount—8-10 slots spent on
ramp is common. By contrast, most 60 card decks
do not—you will get specific decks focused on
high-cost plays, such as Tron, that focus
a lot of deck space on ramping, and you’ll
get midrange decks that run a spattering of
efficient dorks to hit their impactful 3, 4,
and 5 drops a turn early in some games to
gain a tempo advantage. Broadly, though,
ramp isn’t widely played in 60 card formats
because it often isn’t worthwhile to expend a card
just for a bit of acceleration. This is likewise
true in limited—I’ll run an efficient dork like
a Llanowar Elves and I’ll run a card like Dance
of the Tumbleweeds or Poison Dart Frog that has
some extra utility attached at a good rate, and
occasionally I’ll add some lesser ramp if I have
critical high-cost plays that my gameplan ended
up needing to revolve around. Aside from those
instances, though, it’s almost never correct
to play ramp in draft or sealed—draw is usually
sparse, and mana and cards are better spent
contesting the board and threatening life totals.
The result of all of this is that in formats
outside commander, ramp spells are viewed very
critically—a player must ask themself “why is this
here?” and if that question doesn’t have a clear
and persuasive answer, the card will generally get
cut. By contrast, many people building a commander
deck will throw together their template-built EDH
deck with the requisite count of ramp cards picked
from among the available staples. These will
often be added without consideration for what
the cards are accomplishing—you’ll get Cultivate
in two-color decks with a four mana commander,
Gilded Lotus in decks with an average mana value
of 2.5, Rampant Growth in an artifact-centered
deck with a three mana commander, and so on.
Fundamentally, the issue is that a lot of players
don’t stop to consider what ramp is offering them,
because they’re playing a format where it is an
unquestionable fact of life—I play ramp because
I want more mana, c’mon. Now, in most decks,
this won’t be the end of the world—decks do want
ramp spells, and even if players add ramp that’s a
bit suboptimal for their deck, their deck is still
spending slots on a thing that it needs, and the
specifics can be corrected later. However, just
as there’s variety in how much ramp 60 card decks,
want there will be some commander decks that
don’t really want ramp in any sort of conventional
quantities. I have two different decks where
this is the case—in both my Malfegor deck and my
Francisco Malcolm deck I don’t want to spend the
entirety of my turn 2 or 3 playing ramp spells,
because I have more useful cards I want to be
developing. Both decks include a handful of rocks
for purposes of weaving into a later turn, because
this is still EDH we’re talking about and getting
a future mana boost off of a 1 mana investment
is still useful for keeping up in later turns,
but these aren’t a key card type and each deck
runs only a low single digits quantity of two
mana rocks so as not to draw more than one in the
early stages of a game, plus a Sol Ring to cache
in on my Wizard of the Coast mandated dose of
variance. The step of asking how much mana a deck
actually needs and what times it will want to play
ramp spells is one that a lot of players forget
to complete, and playing other formats where the
inclusion of ramp isn’t such a foregone conclusion
is great for getting perspective on what these
cards are actually accomplishing in a deck.
The same can go for other card types—when is it
correct to exclude or go light on card draw? When
is it correct to exclude board wipes? These are
things that EDH players will consider necessities,
but depending on the deck they might not be
nearly as important as a player might assume.
One other deckbuilding skill that EDH isn’t great
at teaching players is figuring out optimal card
quantities. A feature of singleton formats is that
they restrict how many of a particular sort of
card a player can run. Some cards will have many
similar options, but other types of cards will
be more unique, and a player will have no choice
but to add the number of it that exist to their
deck and no more, regardless of how much they
like it. This outsources a lot of decisionmaking
to the nature of the format—players don’t get
to choose how many cards to add to their deck
that create additional dragons when a dragon
attacks, that decision is already made for
them. Whereas in 60 card formats up to 4 of a
given card can be run, giving players room to
flex counts on various cards up and down and
see how they feel, in EDH there often isn’t
this same level of choice. The result of this
is that when players have access to a greater
number of a particularly appealing effect,
if they’ve played EDH but not other formats,
the instinct might be to load up on all available
copies of that effect, regardless of how many
would actually be optimal for the deck. This is
likely something that will be figured out in due
time so long as players are willing to challenge
their assumptions about how their decks work
from time to time, but having less of an intuitive
sense for how many copies of a card is appropriate
is certainly something that can lead to wasted
time and games played with an off-kilter deck.
Long story short, yes, playing formats outside
EDH can imbue players with important experiences,
experiences that will be especially useful
on the fringes of the commander experience.
Commander players will have no trouble getting
used to playing against snowbally value piles,
dealing with board wipes, building conventional
synergy-based midrange, developing a growing
knowledge of common staples, and so on. Playing
lots of commander will make you better at a lot of
things in commander, and playing enough commander
in diverse environments will even grant a degree
of proficiency in the things I mentioned
earlier—life total management, low resource
environments, unconventional deck types, and so
on. These aren’t forbidden knowledge or anything,
but playing formats outside EDH will certainly
help to instill certain lessons faster than
others, and develop an intuitive sense for why
they’re true. It’s also good to play other formats
because cards are designed for other formats,
and the further back in time a card was printed,
the more it was focused on 1v1 formats. As much as
it can feel like us commander players are playing
in our own little bubble, we’re playing with
cards that are part of a broader game, and having
a better understanding of all facets of that
game will help you as a player across the board.
If nothing else, it’s good to be aware of the
areas of play that we might be a bit weaker in,
and try to gain a bit of experience in them.
To wrap this up, what formats should you
be playing? As far as 60 card formats go,
I can’t speak for the quality of most of them
because I simply haven’t played them recently,
with one exception—Pauper. This all-commons
format is cheap to get into and pretty vibrant,
and its fast-paced but not overly complex gameplay
makes it a great place to dive into 60 card Magic.
Switching gears to limited, my personal favorite
way to play Magic outside of EDH is draft and
cube—the process of drafting from packs and
deckbuilding with the resulting pool is a
skill-testing task all on its own that will appeal
to anybody who loves deckbuilding and also has a
bit of a competitive or spike-adjacent streak.
If those two options sound too intimidating,
if nothing else you should go to prereleases.
These are sealed events—you open six packs
and build a deck with them, simple as.
I personally prefer draft to sealed,
but the exact reasons that make a longtime player
like me have this preference make sealed a great
option for players without as much experience
playing limited. Deckbuilding is more streamlined
and less punishing of mistakes since decks can
be totally rebuilt between rounds if it becomes
clear something went wrong, and variance plays a
greater role in success which means that a less
experienced player who pulls the right selection
of cards can have a fighting chance even against
a Magic veteran. If you want to hear more about
why it’s worth playing non-commander formats and
what formats you should get into, there’s
a whole episode that just released on the
podcast that I co-host goes into more depth about
this, and a link to that is in the description.
With that said, thanks for watching! And thanks
to Archidekt for supporting the channel. One of
my favorite parts about the site is the
visually streamlined folder system that
lets me keep my decks organized with ease. A link
to my Archidekt profile is in the description if
you want to browse the various folders there
and the decks contained within. As always,
I also want to thank my Patrons, some of whom
are on screen now. My final deck review for
the year is taking submissions now, so if
you want a chance at getting selected for
that you can sign up for my Patreon for $3 a
month. You’d also be receiving access to my
back catalogue of bonus videos, which span back
a year on a variety of topics. Alright, bye now.